[موسيقى]
مطر ووسم واعتدال فاذا نزل المطر بالوسم
وكانت الاجواء معتدله فان البادر اول
الربيع يفز بسرعه وهذا ما لاحظناه على
شمال شرق مكه وشمال شرق المدينه والقصيم
وحايل وطريف وعرعر ورفحه وشمال الحفر
وكذلك الكويت والاجازه الطلابيه داخله في
حيز الايام الاخيره من الوسم وهذه الايام
في غالب احوالها لطيفه اذا ضاقت بك
الاحوال يوما فثق بالواحد الفرد العلي ولا
تنزع اذا ما انا بخطب فكم لله من لطفا
خفي
[موسيقى]
ودراسه في الترم الثاني ستكون داخله في
نطاق البرد الفعلي وبعض ايامها سيكون
زمهريرا المربعانيه الشبط العقارب ديسمبر
ويناير وفبراير وهو موسم اش لباس الشتوي
فاخر نجمين من المربعانيه علاوه على نجمي
الشبط اول نجم من العقارب هذه النجوم
الخمسه الابرد في السنه فاول واخر ايام
الدراسه ستكون بارده في الليل ومعتدله في
النهار وفي منتصف الدراسه برد بالليل
والنهار لا تسال الليل عن دمعي وعن وجعي
اي يسكنان وطيف الراحلين معي ادري بهم
رحلوا ما عاد لي امل عقلي وعى غير ان
القلب ليس يعني
[موسيقى]